We are delighted to have in our studios
Dr. Rajendra Pachauri,
the director general
of the Energy Research Institute of
India,
and the chairman of the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change.
He, along with
Mr. Al Gore,
received the 2007
Nobel Peace Prize.
And he was of course
a teacher at Yale University for several years,
and we're delighted to welcome him back to the
campus. Welcome.
Thank you.
Despite all the
news reports that we see, the newspapers,
television,
there is still a considerable body of
opinion,
which believe that this talk of global warming
is a big,
overblown
theory based on
some fragmented data, and perhaps it's only
a cyclical thing,
not something systemic.
So what do you say to the skeptics?
Well let me first say that, you know, the process
by which the IPCC prepares its
report
is the strongest testimony to the strength
of what we produce.
We mobilized the best scientists and experts
from all over the world,
and they are selected on the basis of nominations
sent by governments
and on the basis of CVs of the people
nominated.
Just to give you an example, in the fourth assessment
report we got close to
two thousand nominations,
and roughly 450 were selected as those who directly
wrote the report.
And these are scientists from different branches of science?
Every branch of science
depending on the
subjects we're covering in the full assessment,
and
over and above that we have about 2,500
reviewers
because every draft is carefully reviewed
by a whole range of people,
experts,
and then at the second stage by governments.
Each of the comments provided by the reviewers
is carefully logged,
and the authors decide whether to accept it or
reject it. If for some reason it is rejected,
the reasons have to be recorded.
So you can't think of a more transparent
and open process than this.
Also, may I emphasize that the IPCC does no research
on its own.
It carries out its assessment on the basis
of peer reviewed literature.
And there's a wealth of literature, in fact its
growing so rapidly
now unless all the people who are researching
this
are basically in the business of fooling
the public,
you really can't believe there's anything wrong.
The second point I'd like to make is
you know the number of skeptics
as would be expected has been going down very rapidly.
But, on the other hand if you look at the history
of science and knowledge
in any new discovery, in any new field of
human endeavor
where new knowledge is created,
there are skeptics who will question it for some
time to come.
There are even today people who believe that
the earth is flat.
So, I mean,
what else can one say?
Tell us for our viewers
in brief what the conclusion of the IPCC has been.
Well, firstly let me explain how climate
change has been caused by human actions.
We have been in the process of industrialization,
consuming larger and larger quantities
of fossil fuels,
and there are other gases also which have the
same effect as carbon dioxide,
though carbon dioxide is by far
the most important of these gases.
Before industrialization the concentration
of carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
was 280 parts per million.
It's now in the neighborhood of 380 parts per million.
And may I mention that this concentration
level
was last recorded six hundred and fifty thousand
years ago,
and there are very
well-established scientific methods by
which we can now
assess what the composition of the atmosphere
was
going back
several thousands of,
hundreds of thousands of years.
Now because of this concentration what happens
is
typically
you get radiation from the sun,
it falls on the surface of the earth,
and a good part of it is reradiated back
into outer space.
Now that's what has kept the temperature in
a balance over a period of time, and of course
for natural reasons
there have been variations over a long period
of time.
But with this high concentration of gases
part of what is reradiated back
comes right back to the Earth,
and that causes
an imbalance--Greenhouse effect.
But it's not a smooth and linear change of temperatures only.
As a result of interference with the entire climate system
what we have is for instance
many more floods,
we have changes in precipitation, not totally
at average levels,
but also precipitation patterns, for instance
extreme precipitation events are on the increase.
We have many more heat waves.
We have droughts,
and of course the result of all this is sea level rise.
And the sea is
increasing in its level
both because of thermal expansion
as well as melting of the ice bodies. Now that's
something which is visible,
which is measured,
and people can deny it if they want to,
but all they have to do is
go to the arctic region. I've been there myself.
Go to the Himalayan glaciers,
and you'll see the rapid rate at which the
the bodies of ice on the Earth are
melting.
Just as a matter of fact the arctic region
has been warming at twice the rate
of the rest of
the Earth.
And this naturally contributes to
more water going into the oceans.
So this is how climate change is taking place,
and the only way we can stabilize this
situation
is for us to cut down
on emissions of greenhouse gases
and allow for stabilization of the concentration
of these gases
in the atmosphere.
This
is
very clear as to the
danger involved.
How do you explain
the fact of the
Nobel Peace Prize committee
chose to give
IPCC, you, and
Al Gore the award.
What is the connection between peace and our climate?
Well, I would say that the Norwegian Nobel committee
have been very
far-sighted
in this decision,
which may sound a little self-serving, but
the point is
the result of climate change is certainly sea level rise.
This has inbuilt in it
the element of
displacement of a large population.
If you look at the Maldive islands,
even though it may not be fully submerged
under the water, every time there's an extreme
precipitation event
because of higher sea levels,
the severity of the impacts is much worse
than would have been the case otherwise.
If you look at the tsunami,
which took place four years ago,
and let's assume a similar tsunami was to take place in 2050,
when the oceans
are maybe
even twenty five centimeters higher,
which incidentally is a fairly conservative
estimate.
Look at the devastation it can cause.
If you look at the impacts on agriculture,
and this is something that agricultural scientists
now have enough evidence on.
They're not climate scientists.
They don't believe in
anything to do with climate change, but they're seeing
the impacts on yields and productivity of several crops.
What's that going to do to food security?
Today's New York Times carries stories about
these food drives that that are taking place
all over the world.
That's not a result of climate change,
but the point I'd like to emphasize is that
climate change only exacerbates
the existing stresses on this kind,
whether it's water scarcity
or impacts on agriculture.
And a large number of
poor farmers
in the developing countries are dependent
on rainfall agriculture.
When rainfall patterns change,
when droughts occur
on a prolonged basis, on a repeated basis,
what are they going to do?
They're going to move to areas where they feel
they can at least live and survive.
Doesn't that create the danger of conflict?
So I think the
Norwegian Nobel committee
understood
the impacts of climate change
and how these might get worse in the future,
and therefore
pose a major threat to peace in different
parts of the world.
I think that's essentially the connection.
That is very interesting. Now, the question though is
large population countries like India and China
because of their drive to
grow
because of pressure of population
to give them better life,
they have to produce power, and their
most likely source is coal.
And so the more they're going to coal-powered
electricity generation,
the more
CO2
is emitted.
So how do you square this cycle that you need
to have
growth in order to
reduce poverty,
at the same time the same growth might
lead to poverty
by the mechanism you mentioned.
Well firstly I think we must understand that
climate change
is being caused today
on account of historical factors.
It's in the process of industrialization, which
has taken the developed countries
to unprecedented levels of
prosperity
that we have emitted large quantities of
greenhouse gases,
and these are causing human-induced climate change today.
Now, it's for this reason that the framing convention
on climate change
clearly lays down a common but differentiated
responsibility,
and that differentiated responsibility requires
the developed countries to take the first
steps
in reducing emissions.
Now logically what is expected is while
those countries
reduce their emissions,
the developing countries will continue
to increase their emissions,
but they don't necessarily
have to
emulate exactly what the developed countries
have done.
And therefore I would say that for
local, domestic and national reasons,
the developing countries should certainly look at the path
by which they keep their emissions as low as
possible,
but naturally they're not going to do this
at a higher cost
than what existing technologies will permit.
And today as it happens for a country that
has coal,
they have no choice but to burn coal to produce power.
But what I would say is that
we should use coal as efficiently as
possible,
and we should use all the energy that's
provided to consumers, to industries
and to others
in an extremely efficient manner,
and to the extent possible we should also
harness other technologies
like renewable energy technologies,
which didn't exist a hundred years ago, but they
are available today.
So being as developing countries have to exercise
choices
that will promote sustainable development.
We cannot possibly do this just because
the developed world
has followed a particular path
that we must do exactly what they have done because
they have made mistakes,
and the cost of those mistakes
are now being felt
In the most unprivileged regions of the world.
There have been some
demand that the developed countries
should provide
either financial assistance
or technological assistance
to the countries
in order to reduce the CO2 emission.
Do you think that that is
a possibility? Well again, that is clearly
laid down in the framework convention on climate
change.
There I must say the developed countries have not done
anything substantial.
And if you really want to promote
sustainable development
and a climate-friendly path of development
in the developing countries
then I think
the developed countries
must facilitate
the adoption of
clean technologies,
financing of some of the infrastructure, which
incorporates these clean technologies,
but that has really not been done so far.
And I think the demand for
action in this area is now
getting much louder,
and therefore the industrialized countries
will have to pay heed to it.
The fear is
that this you do first
before we do,
this argument the west is saying
that unless you start
capping your emission,
we are not going to do it,
how do you resolve this dispute?
Well, I think it's a very unfortunate dispute
because
I think it's not totally inequitable, to my
mind it's also unethical
for the developed countries to insist
that the poorest countries in the world
should take the first steps.
I mean look at the reality of India.
Yes, we are increasing our emissions, but what is
it in per capita terms?
Barely one ton per capita per year.
And if you take the US, it's over twenty tons
per capita,
so you know the huge disparity that
exists today
really can't be wished away,
and I think you also have to accept the fact
that in India there are four hundred million
people
who have no access to modern energy or electricity.
So how can you deny them that?
I mean every slum-dweller in India
watches television.
What do they see on the good life?
He sees the western pattern of
living,
and he feels am I not entitled to the same
thing?
So I think there has to be a common effort
in both parts of the globe
by which
the developed countries cut down their emissions rapidly,
and this will require much more efficient
use of energy,
much less dependence on fossil fuels,
and I would say even changes in lifestyles.
There has been some criticism
of the IPCC
reports, saying the IPCC report grossly
underestimated
the
growth of the undeveloped countries
and secondly
the challenge up producing alternate energy sources.
How do you respond to that criticism?
Well, you see,
as I explained earlier the IPCC goes by
peer reviewed literature,
and there's a wealth of information that is available.
We have to take a balanced view
that always some publications--
just to give you an example,
there is growing concern that sea level rise
in this would
may rise to several meters,
and that could happen
if let's say the western arctic ice sheet
or the Greenland ice sheet
were to collapse. Now these are deglaciating,
they are melting very rapidly,
so that possibility exists.
But you know the IPCC cannot take
an extreme view on these things because firstly
we cannot predict if it could
happen,
and let's see if it could happen when it's
going to happen.
So we are in no position to make that kind
of a projection,
and we have to take the balance
of knowledge and what's contained in the literature.
In the case of the growth rates of the
developing countries,
we have a whole range of scenarios we can assess.
And these are very plausible scenarios.
They take into account
high rates of growth, high rates of technological
evolution,
high rates of population growth,
so we have covered
all the possibilities that one can foresee
on a reasonable basis in terms of
economic growth and development
in the twenty first century.
So that criticism is not valid.
We have a wide range of projections we have come up with.
How...in the development of
new alternative technology
where is the
initiative going to come from?
Because some people say there should be a
Manhattan-like project
for the governments to put in
large sums of money
to promote development of alternative technology.
You know you really need a range of initiatives.
Firstly you've got to
have a policy framework
that promotes
expenditure on research and development. Yes, governments
can certainly spend more money on R&D.
But companies
and business organizations also need to do
that.
When will they do that?
When you have a price on carbon.
And I think it's absolutely essential if we want to move
towards lower emissions of carbon dioxide
that we must place a
price on carbon.
If we were to do that
then business, industry
and consumers
will move towards
low-carbon options.
But we don't have that today,
and I think this is where
governments must see their responsibility.
I was very
bothered to read one of the leaders
over here in this country
saying that we should do away with taxes
on gasoline.
Now to me that's a backwards step.
I don't think we should indulge in these
populist measures
if they're going to hurt
this country
and the world.
And may I say that it's in the interests of
business
in the US
to move towards low-carbon technologies
because that's what the future's going to
be.
The question of
keeping quiet, people are saying
at least I think Jim Hansen has written a piece
for YaleGlobal in which he's
arguing
there should be zero
carbon
emissions
achieved
by 2030,
and
the level
of PPM should be brought down to 350
by the end of the century. That is the
optimum he is asking for. Do think
it's feasible?
Well I think it's really a question
of what we
identify as threat.
If the threat is large enough, there have been
occasions where the word had to fight wars,
and in fighting those wars they have given
up a lot,
they have made some major
adjustments
in the way the economy grows, in the way people
consume
goods and services.
The whole issue of the tipping point is
something which involves a value judgment,
and I
think one aspect of this issue is not given
enough attention at all,
and that is
the aspect of different countries
and their perceptions and their interests.
If you talk to the president of the Maldives,
as I've done on several occasions,
he'll tell you that we've crossed that tipping point
because
I remember in 1997 there was an IPCC meeting,
which was organized
in the Maldives,
and he stood there before us
at the inaugural session. He said ladies and gentlemen,
the place where you're holding this meeting
ten years ago was full of water,
it was under a foot and a half of wter
because there was a huge
storm surge,
which brought in large quantities of water in
this island, and
most of the islands over there are
a meter or a maximum of two meters high.
So if you talk to the small island states,
if you talk to people in coastal areas or
those in sub-Saharan Africa,
they'll tell you that the tipping point has been crossed.
Now the question is when you come up with the global response,
whose concerns are you going to take into account?
Gandhi had a philosophy
where he
talked about "until death",
which means
the impact
on the most underprivileged, the last man.
I think if
world is taking a decision
on what needs to be done,
I think we should keep in mind
the most...
the worst affected
nations or societies in the world
in defining what the tipping point is.
I don't think we're doing that.
We're only concerned about ourselves,
and since this is a very unequal worlD,
unfortunately it is the prosperous who seem to lay down
the requirements of what needs to be done
and
what is not to be done.
Precisely because of that concern, a
lot of people
fear that the Copenhagen Process, the next
step of Kyoto 2,
might be taken
in a direction by the developed countries,
which will again
serve their interests and not the interests of the planet.
What do you see is the prospect of
Copenhagen?
Well I personally feel there is a major change that is
taking place, and I
don't think as chairman of the IPCC,
I feel the IPCC should
get the credit,
but certainly
the impact our reports have had last year
has been astounding,
and I think it will change  public opinion
all over the world.
Therefore
my
hope is that
since the public is now so concerned about
the impact not only in other parts of the
world,
but even in this country,
that there will be a strong resolve and
a desire
to take the right steps.
Also we can't wish away the fact that the
developing countries
including the emerging markets
are no longer lightweights who can be bought,
they have a voice in global affairs.
And therefore I think
their perceptions will have to be taken into
account.
So one hopes that there will be a fair
and equitable agreement that we come up
with in Copenhagen, but
I do realize there are several pitfalls and
problems along the way.
Well, on that somewhat
positive note,
thank you very much for all your time.